thrill to have right here a good friend
from my NFL Network colleague set as
well as just life in general haven't
covered him for all those years in San
Diego and then the New York Jets the
college football and Pro Football Hall
of Famer part of NFL Network's 19
million hours of coverage on Sunday of
Super Bowl 50 for good to see you
LaDainian Townsend million that's
correct right I read that straight from
release 19 million hours of coverage
so now Dion was here yesterday saying
he's just doing the post but you are
versatile right
yes he's catch and run I do you can do
it I can throw it to that you could
throw it - yes you have the option in
you so you're doing pre and post I'm
gonna do some stuff I believe during
your show okay good
but later not early in the morning it
has to be late again yes that's the
option again so you'll be you'll be
showing up later we'll be getting there
starting an hour call time is the crack
of dawn we're on the air at 9 a.m. right
right inside the Hard Rock where I
haven't been in that Stadium last time I
was in that stadium was the Cameron wake
off safety on a Thursday night to beat
the Cincinnati Bengals and open up there
I've never seen a walk off safety before
that the building's supposed to be how
do you remember that stuff it's just
well I mean don't you remember plays if
you're correct do but you're talking
about a safety you know that and in a
game well I've never have you ever seen
a walk off safe they have not but I
really don't care that play was crazy
that was that yeah the fact that an
tdawg was throwing the ball and the
white hard line at all and okay you
gotta get on my TCU guys I don't mean to
do that
oh the rest of America just means to do
that it's one of the sweetest guys
you'll ever meet to see y'all no doubt
about that but yeah I mean don't you
remember like how I remember a third
quarterback in this game back in that
day you remember that stuff right there
are certain things I actually yeah
games that are playing in your course
absolutely that's me butts these are
games that I brought yeah that's right I
just don't tear drop the microphone when
I make a good line you know great
broadcaster there I appreciate a bark
would be know if I'm if I'm ever is
known as the LaDainian Tomlinson a
broadcast as I will take because I lift
my teammates I lift my Jewish merci
Michel the best running back in the game
Sunday is is which i think is rahim most
ER i think just what he's been doing
this playoffs what a story what a story
right
perseverance always believing in
yourself that you had the talent to get
it done i meanwhat seven different teams
you know but at the same time when you
think about it he was a third string
running back at the beginning of the
year right you had coleman you had Breda
and then you know he was a god that was
supposed to just play special teams and
kind of give them depth but there was he
flashed last year if you remember there
were a couple games that row him most ur
like had incredible games and he
displayed the speed and the power and
all the things that we're seeing now he
displayed it a little bit last year so
I'm not totally shocked of the year that
he had but I think right now he's hot
you know and as a runner when you're hot
you know things I mean you you feel like
everything is gonna go well out there
yeah and Tevin Coleman started the NFC
Championship game in which he set all
those records and we'll see if Coleman
is going to be able to go on Sunday and
you know he's desperate to make
obviously that this game but it looks
like it's gonna be most 'red starting
and then speaking of hot I mean he's hot
going into the game figuratively like
like where he apparently off you're a
Game of Thrones fan or you're like Arya
Stark like reads off on a list of people
who have slighted him all the teams and
the dates that he was cut by the teams
he said he reads those dates before he
goes out on the field Wow and then he's
viewing the opponent like these are the
guys who are card and taking yeah cut me
or took that's what fuels athletes him
most of the time when you think about
some of the greatest athlete
they're fueled by what someone told him
that they could not do I mean look at
possibly the greatest quarterback of all
time Tom Brady
there's always fuel yeah by their chip
on his shoulder being drafted late and
nobody believing in the Brady six even
though he's got six in the case the
Brady six still pisses him off to this
point yeah where he want seven did you
ever have anything like that well yeah
if you remember coming out of college it
was oh he played at a small school he
ran the option how fast is he can he
catch the ball Kenney playing the pro
style offense all those things I took
cutouts from those magazines and those
those draft reports and I put them on my
wall you know my senior year so I can
look at them and that's what few of me
that entire season and even if you go
back to look at some of those old videos
of me in college look at the the risk
tape what I had written on my wrist was
it it was a feat the family and
underrated feed the family and then
underrated so that was the pressure that
I was playing with when I was in college
well the feed the family is the pressure
the underrated is the fuel right I mean
that look as the fuel that's yeah
underrated no question you know Maurice
jones-drew of Ward number 32 because he
was a second-round pick and he wore 32
for the number of teams had passed on
him in the first round I mean there are
so many things like that you know I'm um
and I'm just wondering how much fuel
there is to the fire for most dirt and
every so many of these guys that are
playing in this Super Bowl have have
never been there before and this is a
big moment for them and I wonder how
much that's gonna actually matter in the
game if everybody's in that same boat
you know I think it only matters in your
preparation I mean because all the big
games I've ever played in it really
matters in how you prepare for the game
but rich I'm telling you once that ball
get kicked off you're so focused on the
task at hand and getting the job done
and and really just doing everything
possible to make sure your team wins
right that you don't have time to think
about the pressure you know of man this
is the Super Bowl this is a championship
game you know and so I don't think it
matters when the ball kicks off I think
right now it definitely matters because
you can't tell me that a god that has
been here before like a Richard Sherman
it's not prepared he knows what to do
there and this week he knows to get
everything he has to get taken care of
with family and friends right early
right and then he knows when to lock in
and get ready for the game these other
guys are trying to figure it out because
they have never been here before
latane Ian Tomlinson here on the Rich
Eisen show and then another guy that's
got sort of that fuel to the fire is
Damian Williams lead lead back of Kansas
City he's coming to the stadium I mean
we were all talking about tan Hills
coming home potentially but Damian
Williams was a guy that the Dolphins
were like you know what we got Kenyan
Drake until he fell out of favor for
whatever reason they just kind of let
him walk to Kansas sitting for hardly
anything and now he's coming back here
to play in the Super Bowl the again is
maybe he's getting a police escort by
our Butler I said right now but how
important is and how do you
the screen game is going to particularly
play a role in this because we all hear
about that front four of San Francisco
and how they're gonna try and hunt
mahomes and I don't know if there's a
better screen team in the NFL right now
than what Eric the enemy and and Andy
Reid cooks up on that field I wonder
what you think about that that's a great
point rich and as the way you slow some
of the greatest defenders down
especially on the defensive line is the
screen game and you're right Kansas City
does a heck of a job running this screen
game but Damian Williams is a heck of a
runner and actually he's my second best
running runner in the Superbowl you know
he is a guy that doesn't need a lot of
carries he doesn't need a lot of touches
to make an impact on this game it seems
his dome every time Damian throughout
the course of a game his touches are
always effective don't don't at some
point he's gonna make a play for his
team through the screen game or just a
great run a long run to really put the
game out of out of distance for the
Kansas City Chiefs and here's the other
thing he's a great runner around the
goal line if you think about how the
Kansas City Chiefs score yes they throw
the ball and they you know move the ball
through the air from 20 to 20 but
generally they like to run the ball into
the end zone that's usually Damian
Williams right around the five-yard line
running the football so I don't think
it'll be with the screen game just about
Damian Williams Tyreke he'll I believe
they'll screen do some screens with
Tyreke he'll and some maybe Miguel
Hardman you know so I just think the
screen game is gonna play a big factor
because you have to keep that defensive
line off-balance and not allow him that
not allowed them to just tee off on
Patrick Mahone I would definitely keep
an eye on that screen game you want to
ask the poll question of LaDainian
Tomlinson Chris cos that we've kind of
touched around the edges of what you've
cooked up today what do you got over
yeah we're looking at X Factor's
LaDainian who'll be the biggest one in
Super Bowl 54
two from each team on the offensive side
of the ball San Francisco debo Samuel
Kendrick Bjorn for Kansas City Damian
Williams me Cole Hardman I made him take
most dirt out of there because I don't
know if mosters could be considered an
x-factor if he's the starting running
yeah that's um because you would have
hopped on that official San Francisco
tell me who and yeah cuz you're born and
DeBell salmon I think San Francisco has
to be debo Sam you okay because the way
that they utilize debo Samuel you know
he's like the jack-of-all-trades for
them you know and you always have to pay
attention to the end around with debone
right because he creates big yardage in
the run game just by the end arounds and
the jet sweeps and then not to mention a
lot of times when Jimmy play actions is
going to debo right across the middle
you know so I think debo has a chance to
be the X factor in this game without
question anything at Kansas City I just
talked about I think I think his name
Ian Williams I we had to choose one out
of those four who would you choose oh I
thought it was 150 no no no 1 out of 4
you can only choose one yeah I think I
think his deboned yeah he's not a Swiss
Army knife he's a Swiss Army hatchet
yeah he is big he is strong he is he is
a big big individual smelling that that
comes downhill and hits you hard and and
I mean if we're missing anybody I don't
know if he's gonna be active but LeSean
McCoy is on this team that's right and
if he's up and he could go I mean he's a
guy that I I would put him on there
Chris if we knew he was going to be
active right the type of game that you
write rich they think they need LaShawn
because this is where he shows up right
you know I can see him being active and
then they end up having a terrific game
a terrific game but he could be like if
he is one of those guys up at around
what would that be about 4:30 4:30 5:00
Eastern when we got the ups and the
downs he was not up for the AFC
Championship game you know and II would
trust him and you know he knows Reed and
you know he has been waiting for this
moment in his whole absolutely life yeah
everybody does it's really amazing at
LaDainian Tomlinson a few minutes left
with with you here on the Rich Eisen
show the word is that the Chargers have
moved on from Phillip or Phillip has
moved out and he's moved on from them or
everybody's moved on from each other if
that happens don't don't you think so it
needs to be brought in for a press
conference and a little bit of a
farewell or a send-off that's fitting
absolutely I think that happens but are
we sure Phillip wants to retire see I
don't know if that'll be that'll happen
until Phillip retires like when he
retires
even if he's gone from from Los Angeles
yeah but I mean I think it'll be kind of
weird that he still wants to play but
you're bringing him back for press
conference to say well he's not gonna
play for us anymore but he might play
for a different team just just seems to
be something off you don't I mean and I
know it's an awkward situation and
that's what makes it seem that way and
at some point in the new stadium number
17 will be on whatever ringer is in that
stadium I think we there's of that there
is no doubt but it just seems to I don't
think but so what when you went to the
Jets you didn't have like a farewell
press I did not San Diego well actually
to that I did yes I did I did that's
right I forgot all about it
I forgot I kind of Philip deserves that
sort of thing if that's what's gonna
happen yeah yeah I never thought about
probably I'm sure that will happen then
okay because out any real you know I had
to think back when you you know kind of
jog my memory that I did have a press
conference and how about the what are
the odds there will be a welcome press
conference to the Los Angeles chargers
for one Thomas Edward Brady as the new
starting quarterback of the charges what
do you think of that idea uh uh you know
hey we'll see what happens there's a lot
of rumors going around what do you think
I'm asking one of the greatest charges
of all time
you know I think there's a lot of
possibilities rich honestly I don't
think is out the RAM to say that Phillip
will be coming back you know I don't
think it's you know as far-fetched to
say that a young quarterback could be
drafted this year by the Chargers do you
know something okay why are you pressing
me because you are you are mr. charger
that I know of personally and I
personally I think Brady is exactly what
the team needs right now
yeah Brady is exactly what the team
needs right now going into this new
stadium that everyone assumes is the
Rams stadium only you know because the
Rams paid for it the Chargers need to
have an identity in that stadium and
they need to have 80,000 people in that
stadium and I think Brady come into Los
Angeles again I'll repeat it my kids
would demand a 12 powder blue jersey oh
I'd do it and they would want to go and
we they want to see it do you ignore Joe
Montana his comments and his advice to
Brady which is stay put
you know what obviously yeah I mean you
have to give credence to that but if he
wants to keep playing and something's
going on in New England area of which
were unfamiliar and something that he
has to decide by the first league year
does he want to go back to New England
and he does look over the steering wheel
and he's like you know what I love
Edelman and I love my guys and I know
that Belichick is the goat coach and I
know we're gonna be in the mix and I
know that the rest of the division
outside of Buffalo isn't going to come
get us and I know I'd have to be in
Holmes's division and I know I have to
move my kids but that's Keenan Allen and
that's Mike Williams and that's hunter
Henry a lot of times Melvin Gordon and
that's Austin Eckler and that's Joey
Bosa and that's Melvin Ingram and
everyone Jerry James
who maybe out of all of them the most
impactful over the next several years
it's tough for me not to think about it
as tough yeah no question I think it'd
be it'll be a very interesting offseason
for us for the Chargers but it's your
board for us in the media talk for the
charge okay very good
speaking as a boat that's why I'm that's
why I'm pret very good that sounds like
you know something latina and Tomlinson
smiling like a Cheshire Cat her before I
let you go it's game prediction time
presented by our friends at DirecTV 4k
at 4k and a quick reminder that the big
game on Sunday has brought to you in 4k
HDR by DIRECTV okay LT Kansas City or
San Francisco - who do you have I like
Kansas City you know at the end of the
day I think my homes is special and I
know that San Francisco has a great
defense and all that kind of stuff and
you know number one against the past and
eighth and scoring and all that great
stuff but the special quarterbacks beat
these type of defenses and I think
Patrick is that special so and you know
when you talk about San Francisco's
running game to try to control the tempo
of the game and the clock and all that
stuff one guys to me is gonna play a
difference that's Chris Jones in the
middle of that defense because the way
you stop zone runs is penetration and
when Chris Jones want to play there is
nothing you can do about it when he
wants to get in the backfield there is
nothing you can do about he's that big
that talented and that dominant and I
think at the end of the day Kansas City
will get more stops on San Francisco
than San Francisco will get on Kansas
City that's lt's very reason for thought
that the Kansas City Chiefs are gonna
win and I am been trying to hold my
horse is a little bit here because it's
a marathon still it's five days till
opening for their kickoff that's it's
tough for me to not sit here and lose
myself in the fact that this is mahomes
this moment that this is it to start
yeah the store for him yeah it's but the
49ers are an excellent deep first fill
with tons of that's why I'm following I
know
tons of talented guys with Sherman on
the back end smelling that second ring
for a different team and there's so much
happening but to me just with mahomes
it's it's tough to not just jump
headfirst into that whole thing
good to see you latina you too written
that's LT everybody right here on the
Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app